las opciones de tratamiento para el
cáncer incluyen terapias locales como
cirugía y radioterapia y terapias
sistémicas como quimioterapia y terapia
dirigida
puede recibir uno o una combinación de
estos tratamientos
existen varias opciones quirúrgicas
según el tipo y el estadio del cáncer
durante una recepción en cuña o segmento
mía se extirpa el tumor y un pequeño
margen de tejido sano
en una lobectomía o lobectomía en
manguito se retira un lóbulo de un
pulmón
durante una neumonía el cirujano retira
todo el pulmón
en una recepción en manguito se retira
una sección enferma de una vía
respiratoria grande y se vuelven a unir
los extremos sanos durante cualquiera de
estos procedimientos su cirujano puede
retirar linfa para verificar si existe
algún signo de cáncer la terapia de
radiación o radioterapia es un
tratamiento local que utiliza rayos de
alta energía para matar o encoger las
células cancerígenas con el fin de
aliviar los síntomas la radioterapia de
rayo externo o rbt se dirige hacia la
ubicación del cáncer desde una máquina
fuera del cuerpo
la braquiterapia o radioterapia interna
a menudo en forma de bolitas se utiliza
con más frecuencia para ayudar a mitigar
el bloqueo causado por el cáncer en las
vías respiratorias grandes la
quimioterapia es un tratamiento
sistémico que utiliza fármacos para
detener el crecimiento de las células
cancerígenas eliminando las o evitando
su división celular una vez que los
fármacos entran en el torrente sanguíneo
se desplazan y llegan a las células
cancerígenas de todo el cuerpo las
terapias dirigidas son tratamientos más
recientes para el cáncer que funcionan
enfocándose en anormalidades genéticas
específicas de las células cancerígenas
una terapia dirigida de base suma priva
al tumor de alimento al impedirle crear
un nuevo suministro de sangre otra
terapia dirigida erlotinib detiene el
crecimiento del tumor al bloquear los
químicos que indican a las células
cancerígenas crecer y dividirse